the campaign to limit abortion rights in
America is getting big pushback across
the country abortion rights activists
held more than 400 demonstrations
yesterday around the country to support
the Roe versus Wade ruling that
established a right to abortion
protesters rally here in New York City
st. Paul Minnesota Portland Maine in
Austin Texas to name a few several
Democratic candidates for president also
appeared at a rally outside the Supreme
Court building in Washington DC at the
same time two hollywood projects cut
ties with georgia over the state's
so-called heartbeat bill that was signed
into law this month
director Reed Morano confirmed on
Instagram that her upcoming show the
power will no longer consider filming in
Georgia and reports say the curse the
Kristen Wiig comedy Barb and Star go to
Vista Del Mar is pulling production from
the state Georgia of course is one of at
least eight states to approve abortion
restrictions this year House Republican
or Republicans hope the measure will
lead to a Supreme Court challenge that
could overturn roe versus wade CBS News
legal analyst Ricky Kleeman this year
Ricky good morning good morning exactly
the person I want to talk to you morning
yeah on this issue now a woman's right
to an abortion is guaranteed under a
decision from 1973 Roe vs. Wade Wade the
long term prospects for that are in
doubt and that's in part because of the
history and how that decision was made
could you walk us through that yes and I
do think that the D the future of Roe
may well be in doubt but we have to
remember how it all began Roe versus
Wade stands for the proposition that
under the Due Process Clause of the
Fourteenth Amendment that women have the
right to have control over their
reproductive health meaning that they
can choose to terminate a pregnancy that
right did not come out of whole cloth as
people would like to say it did when it
sees women were dying women were dying
women were using self-help
knitting-needles hangers and back-alleys
botched abortions the movement of foot
after Griswold versus Connecticut which
is in 1965 which starts to create this
right of privacy for people and it is
extended in row to individuals being
females about their own bodies without
government interference really was
started because of the women's
liberation movement but also by
gynecologist who came to the aid of
seeing these born botched abortions and
we find that all the statistics are
really unreliable because we don't know
how much illegal activity happened but
the statistic most people cite is 17
percent that's 17 out of a hundred women
who had an abortion we're done
have there been challenges where he
since Rho V wave was Pat well
have there been challenges to the
Supreme Court decision since then yes
and fairly constantly because once Roe
was passed in 1973 there was great
activism on both sides and when you have
the people who are against abortion that
what they did was very smart both short
term and long term what they did was
they looked for laws and they to be
passed by the state legislatures that
would put restrictions on abortion and
they also looked to create court cases
that would go up so over time some of
these court cases have appeared before
the United States Supreme Court and some
restrictions have been upheld and where
we get to the time that people thought
Roe would be overturned and there was a
great fervor about it and great fear was
in 1992 when we had the Casey case
against Planned Parenthood and at that
point the Supreme Court said okay that
women do have rights to their own
reproductive health and that the state
cannot put a substantial burden on those
rights RC I guess poll earlier today
Ricky showed that two out of three
Americans do not want this overturn will
that make a difference in the legal
fight well theoretically it should not
because popular will should never be
what causes the Supreme Court to do what
it's supposed to do ethically yeah
however yeah
we have to look at and I think the
example that people can understand is
Brown versus Board of Education you had
years of separate-but-equal and suddenly
you didn't so here you have years of
chipping away at Roe and what may happen
in the future is if you chip away enough
there won't be much to overturn it will
be easier and precedents like this even
50-year old ones they do get overturned
at times well apparently they got
overturned rather quickly since Justice
Breyer around May 13th said that he was
very concerned about the abortion case
because of a 50-year precedence that was
tossed okay thank you
everybody's watching thank you very much